[Music]
debbie is old the senses have been
around for a long time we notice it
every day but as theoretical physicists
we're still mesmerized by it and we have
many puzzles that we don't understand
here and I think we live actually in an
exciting time I mean there Newton is
famous for writing down his equations
for gravity then Einsteins a century ago
has a theory had a theory that replaced
Newton's or at least contained it and
now we are in the middle of another I
think it's a revolution in theoretical
physics that we have again well in the
middle of developing a new view of
gravity a new way of thinking about
gravity and indeed also trying to solve
puzzles that we have with thinking about
it so Newton indeed has wrote down his
equations for gravity how it works is
one over the distance squared with
Newton's constant and the masses in
there and he describes very successfully
how the planets orbit the Sun and when
you calculate using Newton's law how the
velocities of planets behave as a
function of the distance from the Sun
they will go slower and that's precisely
what you observe so this plot is the
theory versus the experiment where we
see the planets nicely lined on what
Newton predicted so Newton's theory is
very well tested although there are tiny
problems that Newton had in explaining
maybe we would apply his theory to say
what happened to the inner planet which
was Mercury it had slight deviations
actually Newton would have predicted
that the orbits were close orbits but
what really happens is that the orbit
circles around a little bit this is a
decorated by the way but every time it
goes around it there's a little
difference in the angle and this can be
explained in Newton's theory if we
assume that there would be one or more
planet closer to the Sun hidden there
with us for us not to be able to see it
it is called Vulcan people search for it
but it was not found and indeed now we
know that this is explained by
Einstein's theory of general relativity
so this was something that didn't follow
from doing
now I'm going to make a jump and
actually go to another object which is
not the solar system but something we
live in as well which is called the
galaxy or the Milky Way and it has some
similar properties in the sense that
most of the matter is in the middle and
there are stars going around it and then
you can ask well does gravity work the
same way there and then if you look you
find that something really goes
different than what Newton and later
also Einstein would have predicted what
I showed you for the planets namely that
the velocities would diminish when you
go as a function of the distance that
would indeed have been what Newton
described or Einstein if you take all
the matter that we see which is in the
center and you go out to the Stars far
out you would expect that the velocities
go down because otherwise they would
move too fast and they would simply fly
out of orbit that's not what's happening
we see that the velocity state concert
and these stars are going way too fast
to be able to hold gravity having them
all together and that's also here in
Andromeda and this is something that has
been seen in many many galaxies and
there's only one way to explain it if
you believe that the Einstein and the
any Newton equations are correct namely
assuming there's more force to keep it
all together and this is the phenomena
we call dark matter
people have to assume that there's more
matter in galaxies than we can see which
has to produce the extra gravity and not
just a little bit in our galaxy is about
30 times more than the matter that you
can see and that's not this a tiny
planet that you could next to the Sun to
explain a little deviation that's a big
modification of really what we currently
can see but we believe and actually
that's most what most physicists believe
that I say Styrian and and also newton's
theory is correct still here and
therefore there must be dark matter
maybe it's not so simple
indeed dark never done should be some
distribution of mass around this galaxy
but before halo but if some particle we
haven't found yet that sort of making up
almost this mass or is there another
explanation
now I already mentioned Einstein I mean
Einstein describes gravity in a very
different way than Newton Einstein
thought about space and time as having a
geometry like well the earth is round
we know I mean also space-time can be
curved according to Einstein and
Einstein wrote down equations that
describe how space and time curve when
it could be matter so instead of
thinking about the force like Newton did
where you have just two masses that
attract each other according to some
given law he thought about the motion of
matter through space-time but that's
matter indeed Kirsch the space-time and
therefore the motion of objects are not
going in straight lines but goes like
say the orbits of the planets around the
Sun and he made a number of predictions
and many actually that have indeed also
being confirmed and one of the first
ones already mentioned to mercury but
also the fact that life bends
so if space is curved you can look at
light rays coming from far and you see
that when that would be coming in a
straight line you would see that point B
but if at first you would actually see
it well actually if it's sitting there
the light would come to us and we see as
if it comes from point B but actually
the light is being curved from something
that's behind the Sun so you can
actually see things happening behind the
Sun because the light curves and this
can be indeed observed and I'll show
some pictures in it in a little while
another prediction that sort of famous
in the last months is that gravity also
can have waves looks like life has waves
gravity also has waves and this is a
prediction of Einstein where for
instance this is like oh if two black
holes very heavy objects can collide
together
they send ripples into the shape or the
geometry of space-time and they
propagate outwards to us and we can see
those little informations of space here
on earth by measuring distances very
carefully and indeed this confirmation
that gravity waves exist is a
spectacular
well verification of Einstein's theory
of general relativity but already
mentioned some cases where it doesn't
really work that well and so this
problem of dark matter I can use
Einstein's theory also to verify this
idea so I mentioned that life is being
bent by gravity so when we have an
object that behind the massive well in
this case it's samsung galaxy or some
Sun cluster or something that's in
between then any object that's behind it
will send its light around the object in
front of it in such a way that we can
see the same image from different angles
so here we see actually something behind
it and it forms a ring in the sense that
light can go from always o sites around
it and it's called the Einstein ring and
it's a beautiful confirmation that
gravity sort of works like a lens just
with lenses we also know we can met like
and you can form images so this is not
what it looks like it's really something
that's behind it where the light has
been bend around it so it's quite
beautiful this can be seen with for
instance the Hubble telescope and began
this figure out how much mass that
should in be in there because by looking
at how the light comes towards us we
might be solving the equations we can
see how much matter should be in the
middle and so this would be indeed a
group of galaxies or stars and then
actually this is the galaxies in this
case and there's some other galaxies far
out and we see it's image being
distorted when we look at it and this is
what such an image would look like so
here if you look carefully you see that
there is this group of galaxies but you
see these little white
which are sort of like circles with the
same shape in the same color you see
actually there is something being
distorted as if there's a lens in front
of it but this is just gravity doing the
work but if we can figure out how much
matter should be in here how much mass
is much more than we can see so it's
again evidence that there must be dark
matter in this or more gravity at least
inside this cluster of galaxies and
again something we don't understand by
just looking at the amount of matter
that we see and this is what's called
strong lensing in the sense that it
really is a lens effect where you see
deformations of the galaxies as we watch
the image there's also something called
weak lensing which is a way you look at
very tiny deformations and you can even
figure out that where all the matter is
sitting except and also the dark matter
is sitting and these are images which
they core in where you can see dark
member in the blue and the ordinary
matter that we know about which is red
and the interesting thing that the dark
matter is so surrounding here the
ordinary matter but he is being even
separated from the two
[Music]
you